five oh wow got out of range of the low
aching what a whiff pun is with the
electric but the wall messes up the
combo
sidewall save lives i got a shirt that
says it
oh
keeping the stance right now oh and ak
not sure what to do what an interrupt
with the johnny fist combo
oh my god they're down for one street
four the book one point away from moving
on to grand finals
oh oh okay get the hell sweet oh do it
again he's gonna do it again i said do
it again
and then make sure you take these bags
in the house three
get the break
oh my god down 4-1
takes the okie
try to get the tackle man the little
legs
oh wow bad punish one two to get the
knock down down two no punish
that's gonna hit and that is gonna hurt
like hell
are you you're not dead
that's no way
okay okay okay okay
oh the sprinkler
one the robots oh no that could have
been something big try to go for a
launcher hop kick mr recoil can take it
oh no erotic hair on the kids
big launcher oh my god down four two one
from julia yo missed the recoil no drops
the combo goes for boys oh my god
there's no way go up now go and arrow
again follow up oh my god
oh my god recoil
[Music]
[Music]
you